for more on China Hong Kong and
America's role in the world joining me
now Secretary of State Mike Pompeo mr.
secretary thanks for being here Brett
thanks for having me on this evening
great to do again heard you talk about
the companies American companies warning
them to keep forced labor labor out of
their supply chains pointing directly at
China and these concentration camps as
described by the Defense Department will
we see investigations and prosecutions
of American businesses who don't heed
this warning brett president Trump's
been very clear the way previous
administrations that dealt with the
Chinese Communist Party by turning the
other cheek and letting them abuse
America is not going to continue
so we've responded across a number of
fronts so you identify want this forced
labor nobody wants to buy products cheap
products that were made with slave labor
in western China they want clarity about
the the tracing of the product that they
have and so we've asked every business
to evaluate their supply chain and make
sure that nothing like that ever gets in
and we've put them on notice for actions
that we may take as we move forward
you know last month president Trump told
Axios that he held off sanctions
sanctioning Chinese officials involved
with the mass detention camps because it
would have interfered with his trade
deal with China should those have been
separated right I've been secretary
state for two and a half years now
there's always complex trade-offs that
one has to make president Trump's been
very clear when he signed to this bill
the Weger bill last week that we were
going to take this seriously we were
going to deal with it we were gonna put
harsh restrictions in place we're
working on that no country has responded
in the same way that we have we hope the
whole world will join what's going on
there brett is historic
there's forced sterilization forcing
women to have abortions this is a place
with some of the most fundamental
violations of human rights that the
world has seen in an awfully long time
president Trump's been serious about
making sure the world sees us and we
hope that countries all across the world
including Muslim countries in the world
will see their way clear to putting
putting their shoulder to the grindstone
to help resolve this problem as well yes
the question is should the president
have done more yet a lot of
opportunities talking with President Xi
there's there's no country that has done
I'm confident we'll do more bread all
right in Hong Kong you we did the story
there about the new security law in
place you've certified that Hong Kong is
no longer sufficiently autonomous again
should the administration have acted
more forcefully to deter Chinese
crackdown in Hong Kong I tell you I wish
previous administration had taken China
seriously it's truly this isn't partisan
40 years of failed American policy with
respect to China this administration is
trying to clean it up trying to get it
right the Chinese have taken advantage
of us an advantage of us in multiple
ways we've done really good work
important work trying to protect the
freedoms of the people of Hong Kong
general secretary she has chosen to go a
different direction and we're responding
in a way that will put pressure on
Beijing and tried to maintain whatever
we can of the remaining freedoms in Hong
Kong I will tell you the notion that
there remains one country and two
systems is fundamentally at odds with
the facts on the ground today
you know I regret that you know you that
your critics including now john bolton
say that this was all about election
politics and get China to buy soy beans
in places that effect re-election
nonsense okay that's what we'll get from
that what is success look like with
China the US and China what does it look
like Ken trying to be a responsible
partner with President Xi at the helm in
the Chinese Communist Party look at that
that's up to the Chinese Communist Party
that's their decision to make what the
United States can control us what we do
when there's unfair and non reciprocal
trade we're going to demand by demand
that it be right when they don't do it
we're going to do things like placing
tariffs on their goods when they engage
in behavior that's militarily
threatening to the United States we're
gonna put 700 billion dollars into our
department defense to keep Americans
safe and secure when that Chinese engage
in cyber espionage
we're going to impose penalties on them
such that they will be deterred from
doing that those are the things we can
do we are hopeful we want the Chinese
people to be successful the Chinese
Communist Party today has made a
decision it wants to be an imperialist
power
it wants to be authoritarian in nature
and it wants to compete across the world
in ways that are inconsistent with
the good things happening for the
American people and frankly people
democracies all across the world
president Trump's policies are aimed
squarely at reversing that I want to
spend some time on the Russia bounty
story in Afghanistan first does the
Russian government have American blood
on its hands in Afghanistan Brett I
don't want to get into the intelligence
the intelligence community has put out
two statements I used to have that job
I'm gonna I'm gonna honor what they said
here's what I can say with absolute
certainty the United States has
responded appropriately to the threats
that have been presented to it in
Afghanistan consistently during my
entire three-and-a-half years versus CIA
director and now as Secretary of State
there are many folks using the Taliban
or who have used the Taliban over years
and years and years as proxy forces
there's been money funneled in there
from all across the world unfortunately
President Trump is taking this seriously
we are hopeful we'll make progress on
our peace and reconciliation plan and we
will respond to any threat whether
that's Iranians using the Taliban or the
Russians we'll make sure they know the
Russians have been providing weapons to
the Taliban for an awful lot of years
and so this is an ongoing challenge we
have and our forces on the ground under
general Miller and the resolute support
mission are deeply aware of the threat
from the Taliban whether that's
supported by any third party or none but
you know you just referenced you were
CIA director there's not often consensus
across the intelligence community on
Intel and if it dealt with bounties
killing American troops shouldn't the
president have been told about it we
know that it was discussed in the
National Security Council the principles
in the deputy's level you said today
that key members of Congress had that
Intel as well even though there wasn't a
consensus why was the president briefed
on it well Brett that it's actually not
quite right most intelligence that's
read it there is in fact a consensus
almost all the analytical product that I
read every day has a consensus across
the entire intelligence community that
is often the case that it is not that
happens when that happens we need to
make sure we get it right but Brett you
know this every morning I wake up
and I read the intelligence material so
when I read them there are people all
across the world who threat including my
officers and embassies all across the
world we don't always make sure that
gets to the president we do the right
thing we make sure the ambassador on the
ground knows that the commander on the
ground knows that our allies who may be
threatened as well know it is the
tactical and operational response to
keep our soldiers safe and secure that
is most important when the intelligence
community feels like something rises to
the level it needs to get to the
president I am very confident they will
consistently present it to them I know
that when I was the CI director I did
that did you know about this particular
Intel piece you know I don't want to
talk about the Intel in particular on
this Brett all right I mean there's just
I just I'm not trying to be clever
there's just so much that has been
reported that is not accurate and it is
incomplete that by refuting any
particular element of it I'm putting at
risk our capacity to actually resolve
and figure out what's going on and I
want to ask you about that and the leak
itself but here's what the Democratic
nominee is saying about it either reads
and or gets briefed on important issues
and he forgets it or he doesn't think
it's necessary that he need to know it
he should at a minimum have picked up
the phone and said Vladimir old buddy if
any of this is true and it doesn't cease
immediately you've got a big problem all
right so it's not just the Democrats
obviously you have Senator Chuck
Grassley on the Senate floor saying it
demands a serious response you have two
key Republicans in the house Mike McCall
and Adam Kitzinger saying they're
already those who are politicized in
this issue however we cannot use let
politics overshadow the truth that
Republicans and Democrats a life can
agree on the Putin regime cannot be
trusted if the intelligence review
process verifies the reports we strongly
encourage the administration to take
swift and serious action to hold the
Putin regime accountable breath there's
been no administration to hold the
Russians accountable in the way that's
one s I only wish former Vice President
Biden had held the Russians accountable
we've been cleaning up a lot less of a
mess I wish he provided arms to the
Ukrainians I wish he had gotten out of
there
trudi I wish he hadn't allowed and
invited the Syrians that Russians into
Syria I could go on but you've got a
short show the the failures of the
previous administration allowed the
Russians a lot of space to move we've
pushed back we sanctioned more Russians
than any other administration in history
well take a backseat to no one with
respect to what our administration and
President Trump has done to hold
Vladimir Putin accountable when he's
engaged in malign activity and should we
find out that there's evidence that he's
putting our soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines at risk anywhere in the world
including in Afghanistan I am very
confident confident the president Trump
will direct me and he himself will
respond appropriately how damaging was
this leak he wore CIA director the White
House press secretary the other day said
that there were rogue officers in the
intelligence community who want to
undercut the president you believe that
right I don't know where this leak came
from but when periodicals report this
information it breaks my heart
because it puts our intelligence
officers and our military men and women
at risk it is it is dangerous it is
unlawful and I hope that we can figure
out who did it and they'll be brought to
justice
mr. secretary you did speak out when it
was alleged that Iran was paying the
Taliban $1,000 for each American killed
in Afghanistan as a member of Congress
and you spoke out about the Obama
administration's response at the time
which obviously you criticized in the
overall Iran deal yes it's absolutely
true I've spoken about the Iranians
providing assistance to the Taliban and
my current role as secretary of state as
well I've criticized other governments
we've worked to make sure Pakistan
wasn't providing safe haven for the
Taliban in Afghanistan to know where
equal opportunity when it comes to
making sure we protect Americans
wherever they're serving all right let's
talk about a couple of other substantive
things one is you mentioned the Taliban
peace deal you said that the Taliban
would publicly renounce al Qaeda you
talked about that I asked you about it
back in March ticketless it says it will
not allow any of its members or other
individuals or groups including al Qaeda
to use the soil of Afghanistan to
threaten the security of the United
States and its allies but that's not
really a break that's not a volley
announcing or announcing about
absolute when you say you're not gonna
let them operate there you know Brett
they've done it for 20 years I'm not
gonna let them operate it anymore
that's that as a central provision you
went further saying that they would
eventually take up arms and fight
al-qaeda working alongside us to destroy
al Qaeda have you seen any indication
that the Taliban is doing any of that
yes how but I can't talk about the
things that I have seen but but know
this I spoke with the Taliban again just
this week an effort to further the peace
negotiations to try and get them to the
table with the Afghan government I think
we're closer than we were even just a
couple weeks back the Taliban continued
to have pressed upon them the importance
of this break from al Qaeda and I think
we will be able to see when we get to
that point when we have these
negotiations commenced I think the world
will be able to see that the Taliban are
no got longer going to tolerate what
they've permitted to happen and that the
Pakistanis too will do the things that
need to be done to reduce the footprint
from al Qaeda remember right we're down
to a couple of hundred active al Qaeda
fighters inside of Afghanistan the
reason we went there in 2001 was to
crush al Qaeda that has largely been
achieved can you confidently state that
America will have US troops in
Afghanistan on Election Day President
ultimately make that decision right okay
one more thing the EU blocking travelers
from the u.s. due to the corona virus
pandemic your reaction to that and is
there any pushback from the US well
remember we're not allowing Europeans to
come here today either Brett we're we're
in close conversation with countries all
around the world including European
countries to make sure that when we
reopen our country to travel from their
nations that we do so in a way that
keeps American people safe and reduces
risk from kovin here in the United
States they have a responsibility to do
that for their nations as well and I'm
have every confidence that we'll get
this right with countries all across the
world it's not just the Europeans we
need to get this right we need to get
the economy back up and get people
traveling all across the United States
and international travel as well mr.
secretary we appreciate your time happy
Brannan's day or thank you happy fourth
of July to you dear Brett